c'est moins drôle on en parle chaque
semaine et c'est jamais pour se moquer
c'est la pipolémique de la semaine si
leur histoire d'amour a duré que
quelques heures et c'est pas si il y a
plus de 20 ans Loana reste choqué par
Jean Edouard ça a été un peu l'amour de
sa vie ça s'est fait 3 heures dans une
piscine mais il y a des gens que ça
marche hein
donc dimanche dernier a été invité de
Jordan Deluxe elle est revenue encore
sur Jean Edouard elle est revenue aussi
sur Benoît pas pour les mêmes raisons
mais regardez on peut pas faire les deux
petites secondes de Monsieur Jean
Édouard qui est là d'ailleurs parce que
vous l'avez vu il y a pas très très
longtemps sur Touche pas à mon poste
[Musique]
mais pourquoi il est méchant comme ça
c'est depuis quand qui vous parle mal
depuis la sortie du loft
je rentre s'il est là hop il va aller là
pour éviter qu'il y ait une photo qui
regrette vous pensez ce qui s'est passé
on dirait je la peste
il peut même pas l'approcher elle dit
depuis la sortie du love quand je suis
dans une boîte je peux pas l'approcher
on dirait que j'ai la peste le choléra
lui a répondu aussi et il a dit je vois
Leonard à travers divers articles que je
viens après sur Instagram à travers les
malheurs qui lui arrivent je trouve son
parcours malheureux alors qu'il y avait
un chemin tracé qui avait l'air
magnifique j'appelle ça une descente aux
enfers lui il veut plus l'avoir et dit
que tout ça c'est fini de toute façon il
veut plus voir le loft et tout ça dès
qu'on invite il veut plus entendre
parler lui il a tourné la page de la
télé-réalité et de louana alors il faut
dire que Loana et puis souvent parler
d'elle aussi pour ses déboires c'est
postes sur les réseaux sociaux en
septembre rappelez-vous on parlait
d'elle à propos de photos à Saint-Tropez
donc on s'était un petit peu inquiet il
y avait des photos et elle avait posté
une vidéo pour faire une mise au point
justement sur ces photos regardez
alors voilà vous m'avez naturel bon je
sais que vous avez vu des images de moi
pas très très très très
le mien le vôtre tout le monde de temps
en temps on a envie un peu de mais bon
voilà voilà vous la retrouver à côté
d'une piscine ça c'était pour vous
voilà je vous montre un dernier un
dernier doc et franchement ça n'invite
pleurer parce que j'ai tellement
d'affection pour cette fille que j'ai
connu dans le mag et tout ça elle a
posté ça voilà dernièrement pour nous
annoncer qu'elle avait des nouveaux
projets notamment avec Excel alors
Joubert j'espère vraiment que c'est vrai
parce que regardez
[Musique]
la dernière fois j'ai voulu faire une
petite vidéo un peu drôle je crois avoir
compris que elle était mal perçue
j'avais fait un peu la folle dans ma
visite qui est là vous voyez je suis au
même endroit donc tout va bien vous
inquiétez pas il y a pas d'appel à
l'aide et tout va bien pour moi j'ai de
très beaux projets je vais vous
surprendre dans le bon sens
donc deux métiers que vous m'avez encore
jamais vu donc vous réservez la surprise
pour l'instant je travaille donc voilà
j'ai besoin de décompresser j'ai fait un
peu la folle mais vous inquiétez pas
tout va bien voilà
ça me fait de la peine et là mon dieu
c'est un peu la peine c'est une fille
que j'ai que enfin voilà que oui c'est
vrai qu'il y avait tout pour elle que
j'ai connu et tout ça et j'aimais bien
la phrase de le renfortaine qui
reviendra très bientôt il était en
tournage mais abandonne ce qui
t'abandonne je abandonne ceux qui
s'abandonnent mais je crois qu'il faut
pas encore abandonner c'est quoi ces
projets on va être honnête elle peut
plus parler
elle a la coupe trop de malsaint en fait
qui qui sait quelque chose
peut-être une dizaine de fois sur les
deux dernières années à chaque fois elle
m'a parlé d'un nouveau projet et à
chaque fois ce projet n'est pas arrivé à
part un petit peu de chant avec son
complice
j'en ai entendu des projets tu fais quoi
voilà c'est ça
elle veut planche sur un biopic qui
passera en téléfilm sur sa vie à elle et
elle aimerait jouer son propre
rôle non mais quelqu'un d'autre le jour
et qu'elle s'investisse dans un projet
qui peut un peu lui faire sortir la tête
de l'eau et la mettre dans le milieu
entre guillemets du travail et être
entouré par exemple comme quelqu'un que
comme Alexa la rochebert par exemple qui
devrait visiblement l'épauler là-dessus
elle aimerait ça et elle aimerait aussi
beaucoup et ça je sais pas c'est
faisable mais elle aimerait beaucoup
faire partie de la bande de TPMP avec
Cyril qu'elle adore énormément et
qu'elle adore et même dans cette
émission je pense que le producteur il
me dirait oui mais c'est pas grave tu
vois bien qu'elle a fait le niveau
c'est c'est une âme elle est malade
c'est une âme brisée quand on la regarde
on se dit qu'en fait ça fait tellement
de peine parce qu'on voit que c'est
quelqu'un qui qui n'a plus qui est vide
en fait elle est malheureuse ce qui lui
est arrivé peut-être la détruit c'était
déjà quelqu'un qui avait un passé très
compliqué la télé et tout ce qu'il y a
autour ça l'a brisé et on la sent il
récupérable comment on peut l'imaginer
travailler sur un projet
aussi près comme ça rouge avec des
machins les dents et qui parle comme ça
c'est déjà quelqu'un qui ne se respecte
plus qui n'a plus d'unité d'attirer
l'attention et peut-être que si elle
arrive à avoir de l'attention sur
quelque chose comme par exemple un
projet de biopic peut-être que c'est
quelque chose de plus sain
et de faire des grands appels à l'aise
désespérément mais elle prend des
médicaments ça se voit qu'elle veut dire
que je te donne la parole je vais vous
dire quelque chose parce que au sport je
suis avec quelqu'un qui s'occupe de
louer des appartements vous savez
qu'elle est vendu son appartement et du
coup elle dormait un peu d'Airbnb Airbnb
et la personne qui s'en occupe voilà m'a
dit un jour je suis rentré dans
l'appartement parce qu'elle avait pas
payé tout ça je peux pas vous dire tout
ce qu'elle a vu parce que ce serait la
diffamation mais mais tout ce qu'il y
avait elle était allongée comme ça le
chien n'avait pas mangé c'était il la
secoué il appelait les pompiers pour
savoir si elle était vivante je vous le
dis je vous le redis je suis personne
pour donner des conseils je ne fais rien
je dis juste à là ça va trop loin
je veux dire quelque chose moi je ne
peux pas entendre Hugo dire la télé la
brisé ça n'est pas vrai
elle a eu beaucoup de gens mais
profondément qui ont voulu l'aider qui
ont voulu la suit tous ceux qui lui
voulait du bien et elle est restée avec
ceux qui étaient toxiques et ce n'est
pas la télé
qui a déjà la même télé et il a pas été
détruit elle aurait pas eu les moyens de
se payer malheureusement des mauvais
produits tout ça elle aurait été
caissière à Intermarché ou quoi bah
alors elle lui dit plus régulier elle
l'aurait été dans les boîtes de nuit où
ça va être de plus en
plus elle aime ça
elle aime pour Loana quand elle a fait
la bouquin avec Ardisson mais vraiment
beaucoup de gens l'ont voulu l'aider
pour les bons motifs il faudrait qu'elle
coupe avec ce milieu mais c'est ce
milieu qu'elle veut donc parce que
maintenant elle veut qu'on l'aide mon
peuple j'ai dit on peut plus l'aider
vous la voyez là autour d'une table elle
peut pas parler elle a du mal articuler
ou pas on a fait deux on a fait nous
pour NRJ12 et je dis la vérité avec
toute la tendresse que j'ai pour elle
Stéphane Joffre que j'adore qui était
patron d'énergie 12 faisaient en sorte
qu'un assistant tous les matins prenait
un taxi on tournait genre je sais pas à
15h aller chez elle la réveillait la
sortie de chez elle l'habiller et
l'amener en plateau
c'est pas prendre quelqu'un qui va déjà
bien l'aider c'est justement parce
qu'elle va mal c'est l'entourer c'est la
booster c'est pas la mettre à la télé un
truc que j'adore et que je trouve
extraordinaire c'est qu'on est là à
parler d'elle presque chaque semaine et
en fait il y a personne qui fait rien
mais moi j'ai pas votre position
on regarde ses vidéos on fait tout et au
final on est juste là regardez la
polémiquer sans rien faire
de documentaires de machin à la quand on
la mise à la télé à NRJ 12 mois et
Stéphane job quand il a mis il a pas
besoin de Luna on la mettait là pour
qu'elle a un métier des heures je pense
que tout le monde a tout fait qu'est-ce
que tu veux et puis surtout l'aider
c'est pas comme une chanteuse qui aurait
dépérir ou un comédien excellent qui a
plus de drôle elle elle a quoi comme
Talence
elle a pas un talent vous pouvez mettre
en avant
et là où il a raison Jean-Michel c'est
que quand 20 ans après on interview la
seule question qu'on a lui a posé qu'on
lui pose c'était bien la piscine avec
Jean-Edouard tu vois on en est quand
même c'est ça
le pire c'est que toutes les chaînes et
toutes les productions ont déjà toutes
les images de Lana de sa découverte
jusqu'à maintenant pour le jour où elle
décède dans l'heure qui suit il diffuse
le documentaire sur les attentes qu'une
chose c'est la fin c'est pour tout
Mathieu juste pour dire et positif c'est
que on dit plein de choses terribles sur
elle mais aussi un truc c'est que elle
reste quand même encore très médiatique
elle est interviewée très souvent elle
est chez Jordan nous chez closer on l'a
beaucoup fait ces dernières années
publiques la fin aussi donc c'est
quelqu'un qui continue d'intéresser et
ça faut quand même le souligner c'est là
j'ai deux choses la fascination morbide
alors j'ai deux choses j'ai deux choses
à vous dire la première bon c'est
j'avoue que c'est drôle et c'est de
bonne guerre elle a dit pour mes dents
parce que Benoît avait dit qu'elle avait
des un appareil dentaire pour mes dents
sache que j'emmerde Benoît il ferait
mieux de parler tu regardais dans une
glace et faire évoluer QI avant de
parler c'est plutôt mignon c'est plutôt
mignon et sinon la deuxième chose que
j'ai à vous dire c'est un scoop
incroyable à propos de Loana Natacha
Amal et Jean Edouard si vous êtes madame
vous allez vite comprendre et dans un
instant aussi on reçoit tous les
sortants de la